hey youtubers it's Charlie so huge
Ackman just dropped a bomb said he's
only doing one more Wolverine movie and
there's a whole bunch of x-men
apocalypse
Deadpool news so I'll try and explain
everything that's going on and what it
means for the future of the x-men
franchise let's just start with the
Wolverine WTF first cuz most of us
probably grew up with Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine let me know how old you were
when you saw that first Bryan Singer
film if you didn't see it this morning
Hugh Jackman posted a picture this
morning saying one more time just to
clarify that means one more Wolverine
solo movie he's supposed to have a cameo
in x-men apocalypse but that Matt movie
is not gonna Center on him like Days of
Future past did and if you don't know
what the schedule is x-men apocalypse is
coming out May of next year in 2016 the
third Wolverine movie is tentatively
scheduled for March 2017 but I'm
expecting that to change really I think
after the initial shock wears off you
know no more Hugh Jackman Wolverine
pretty soon I think it's not that
surprising most actors leave a role way
before this it's funny in that it flies
in the face of what Robert Downey jr.
has said recently about playing Ironman
he said he's totally gonna ride the wave
into the shore which means he's gonna
keep playing Ironman so people don't buy
tickets for those movies anymore which
is essentially never so at some point
you will see a gray-haired Tony Stark
I'll just go on record as saying Hugh
Jackman is an amazing actor and even if
he doesn't play Wolverine anymore he
will still continue to headline big
blockbuster movies for a long time his
next big movie is actually pan he plays
Blackbeard in pan which is kind of a
musical it's the same team that made
lame is so if you like Hugh Jackman
doing that kind of stuff you'll totally
enjoy this those are probably the big
hundred fifty million dollar movies
he'll continue to make after x-men just
to take a trip down memory lane the
funny thing about Hugh Jackman's time is
Wolverine is that originally he wasn't
supposed to be Wolverine when they were
first putting the movie together when
Bryan Singer was first putting that
original x-men movie together they
wanted Russell Crowe he turned it down
immediately he was like no thanks so
they went down the list and the studio
really wanted Keanu Reeves or Gary
Sinise which I know it sounds totally
weird they ended up picking Dougray
Scott this guy who you probably don't
recognize then he ended up having to
drop out of the movie because he had a
scheduling conflict with the second
Mission Impossible movie and then Hugh
Jackman finally made it on the list
because his
SuperDuper best friend just happened to
be Russell Crowe superstar who suggested
into Bryan Singer the studio wasn't
super hot on the idea but Bryan Singer
was the director he's like I think this
is a good idea Russell Crowe said he's
awesome so let's give it a try in the
rest is history but that is the role
that turned him into the mega superstar
Hugh Jackman that you see today so as
much as it sucks that we're not going to
see any more Hugh Jackman Wolverine just
remember it this is like 2017 we're
talking about when this Wolverine 3 is
gonna come out in terms of stories for
that third Wolverine movie they haven't
officially announced anything but Hugh
Jackman did say that he wanted to do an
old man Logan story before the curtain
closed I think right now that's the best
theory but I did I did put together a
list of my top 5 choices for stories
that they should do I know a lot of
people are really hot on the idea of the
death of Wolverine because they just did
it in the comic books they kind of did
that in the last Wolverine solo film
like where they took his powers and made
him mortal that's what you see in a lot
of these Wolverine movies is they'll
take like aspects of these big Wolverine
story arcs in the comics they never do
carbon copies of the comic book stories
so top 5 Wolverine stories here we go
number 5 Weapon X this is more of a deep
dive into the world of Weapon X as they
were creating Wolverine if they were
experimenting on him lots of torture
really dark they did some of this during
Wolverine Origins I mean like they
showed them creating Wolverine but there
really weren't that many supporting
characters or the supporting characters
that they did have in the film didn't
feel like characters so imagine a movie
told more from their perspective think
of it as more of a Frankenstein Mary
Shelley's story told with x-men
characters if you want to read it it's
Marvel Comics presents number 72 to 84
on to number 4 Wolverine alone this is
like a small story inside of the Dark
Phoenix saga probably one of the most
famous x-men stories of all time I know
they just cast sophie Turner as the new
Jean Grey so I do think they're building
towards a Dark Phoenix movie but I think
by the time they get there by the time
sophie turner is ready for that Hugh
Jackman will have already vacated the
role so there's like a small chance of
this happening but I really want to see
him do it the Hellfire Club has
basically captured all the x-men and
neutralized them and Wolverine has to
slice his way through each one of them
to get his friends back but it's deep in
the throes of Dark Phoenix Jean Grey has
already become the Dark Phoenix and is
going crazy all over everyone so they
did do this they
they'll probably just do like a Dark
Phoenix movie and add this in is like a
couple scenes but I would like to see
them cycle the Hellfire Club back into
the movies just because there's such an
interesting group of characters on to
number three
Wolverine enemy of the state this would
involve a Marvel x-men crossover so it's
slightly unlikely I don't think we're
gonna see a Marvel crossover anytime
soon but Wolverine gets mind-controlled
loses his goes super dark and Nick
Fury has to bring him in with the help
of shield the big antagonist in the
story is the hand working with Hydra the
hand is kind of like this evil group of
ninjas that also shows up in a lot of
daredevil stories so we can actually see
them show up on the daredevil TV series
but I know everyone really wants a dark
Wolverine story at some point I don't
know if they would want to close Hugh
Jackman's run as Wolverine on a really
dark note but it would be a really bold
move on to number two slightly more
positive choice Kitty Pryde and
Wolverine this is from Chris Claremont
run no surprise there probably one of
the most famous x-men writers of all
time the story just follows Wolverines
adventures with Kitty Pryde and more of
a parental child senpai context Papa
Wolverine takes young Kitty Pryde under
his wing who in this story is way darker
than we've seen in the movies imagine
like a Bad News Bears version of Kitty
Pryde like just really down and out on
our luck Hugh Jackman is definitely at
the right age where he can totally pull
off dad Wolverine Kitty Pryde though I'm
not so sure about because Ellen Page
might not be coming back anytime soon
they'd have to recast the role probably
because I think when she came back and
Days of Future past that was a one time
thing even though she does still look
like a little girl she can still totally
pull off a little girl but I think the
x-men producers are trying to cycle in
new younger versions of the characters
just so they have a little more
longevity this is like a really perfect
senpai Wolverine story especially one
that involves a really strong female
character and it seems like the x-men
films like apocalypse for instance are
centering more on the female characters
like x-men apocalypse obviously gonna be
about apocalypse but mostly it's gonna
Center on Mystique's character because
obviously you know Jennifer Lawrence
biggest star on the planet right now
Kitty Pryde also one of the best female
x-men characters of all time so I just I
really want to see more Kitty Pryde in
the movies if possible and of course my
number one pick for a Wolverine movie
story old man Logan not only is it one
of the best Wolverine stories of all
time
I think the
matically it's a good bookend for Hugh
Jackman's run even though even though
it's kind of dark Wolverine gets
mind-controlled like he does a couple
other times in the comics kills a whole
bunch of his friends goes super dark
like pronounces the title of Wolverine
and ages into this future where the
villains of the world have taken over
the only reason I think they wouldn't do
a story like this
is is because this is like the slam to
black ending where it's like how are we
gonna fix this and then they fix it like
in the next big team up movie if
Wolverine kills a bunch of his friends
kills a bunch of the x-men how they
gonna explain that like I mean how
they're gonna do another x-men franchise
film if they just recast all those young
actors so they'd have to find a way
around that they'd have to have like a
bunch of redshirt x-men characters for
him to kill but it's such an amazing
story that I just I don't see them not
doing it at some point whether or not it
happens with Hugh Jackman or some future
actor so here's my big question for you
guys what story from the comics do you
want to see them do for Hugh Jackman's
last Wolverine solo film even though I
said they already adapted some of death
of Wolverine for the last Wolverine film
I do think that they could do a death of
Wolverine story and it would totally
work if you haven't read that storyline
in the comic books it gets into the idea
of multiple Wolverines after the death
of Wolverine so there are number of
directions they can take the death of
Wolverine story even if they do change a
bunch of stuff from the comic book story
I know a lot of you guys are asking
about the recent x-men casting they just
cast Jubilee for the movie I think you
know like I said they're going with
super young characters and all the
versions we've ever seen of Jubilee have
always been really young teen girls most
of my memories of the character come
from the 90s cartoon series and she was
kind of a silly character like here's
some fireworks here you go so I'll be
interested to see what they change about
that for the movies the funny thing
about the Jubilee character is is that
when they first introduced her in the
comics she was intended to replace Kitty
Pryde inside the uncanny x-men title
because Kitty Pryde had gone to
Excalibur so it's like uncanny x-men one
of the most popular comics of all time
lost one of its most popular characters
so like okay we need to bring someone
back in to be the young teen girl
thus Jubilee was created although she
never became as popular as Kitty Pryde
ever was there was also some really big
Deadpool news that just posted Ryan
Reynolds posted this picture of himself
doing like a very Burt Reynolds type
pose on top of a bearskin rug in front
of a fireplace they also released some
info
about how the movie is gonna tie in with
the other x-men films so I'm gonna do a
separate Deadpool video for all that
stuff be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll post it before Walking Dead stuff
starts tomorrow
seriously big weekend for bloody stuff
it's gonna be really fun why you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about this special Game of
Thrones teaser that Jaime Lannister just
dropped it is really funny and you can
click here to start learning more about
the daredevil TV series that's actually
coming in a couple of weeks thank you so
much for watching
that's all high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you